[Music]
wake up buddy it is walk o'clock
maybe i should let him sleep
okay
[Music]
[Music]
and um okay we'll go for a walk
i have an owner and he's superman let me
just turn that out
i should call me iron man
no
my dog's the best but he's not the
greatest with other animals what is new
with you fellow normal dog i bit the
fedex guy the other day who is he
working for general zod the legion of
doom
fedex of course the federation of exes
not to be trusted
what is taking my owner so long
well well well
if it isn't the justice league
superman
what's going on
you're super strong i should be a lot
more dead right now right
my best friend is in danger and you have
to help me well we're just a bunch of
shelter pets but they're stronger than
you think the mighty oil
i didn't see anything show on wheels
where the heck am i indestructible
when one has an abundance of power
they have a certain duty to use that
power to
[Music]
sorry
you were saying something
how much did you have to drink i had two
toilet bowls and a bidet but day two
just which is crazy i didn't even know
that was a thing but it's like a dog
water fountain
oh out of the way cat child
hey deploy k9g what is a k9
evade
excellent shielding that seemed
incredibly painful
anybody want to switch powers
these rings signify the commitment
so help me thomas sorry sorry
life or death situation i need you to
use the ring to save me like right now
snow my god oh boy
ah hawaii i just hope we are not too
late oh lord there are two of them now
what's happening okay quick version
robotnik is back
i discovered the source of ultimate
power
we need to get it back for the world is
doomed
you got some kind of
space porcupine
i am an echidna warrior
hmm
hedgehog
it's time to say goodbye to humanity
welcome
to the new norm
this is your moment to be the big hero
bad time to say this but i don't
actually have a plan
hey you got a little something on your
uh
someone call an uber
it's cold in here let's turn up the heat
oh great the winter soldier
fear not citizens you are terrible at
this your negative attitude is not
helping
please stick together
no matter what
you're unskilled
untrained
unworthy
you forgot
one unstoppable
[Music]
stand still and god for a guy named
knuckles you are really bad at punching
i am known by many names
stop it
[Music]
you like me
[Music]
and the rest of you play double time
hey giant
hey you wanna see something cool
get home safely good night
you're still here
okay okay one more number i call this
one the legend
will never die
[Music]
i have bad news you died
[Music]
doctor
relax i am [ __ ] booze i have night life
and how many times have you died already
uh
i am not really a mad guy
hold up
do you like asparagus
does this have shellfish in it
a cat always lands on his feet what
what happened
watch
and then there was the giant today so
what is that like
a four
that makes eight puss what do you wish
to do with your last life when you only
have one life
that's what makes it special
drive pedro
fear me if you dare
goldilocks and the three bears crying
family
you're supposed to be dead
it never fails whenever i team up with
you things go wrong trust me
you gotta trust him look at those eyes
you call that cute oh
and with the paws it's all so
cute
am i doing it stop you're gonna give
yourself a harney
[Applause]
[Music]
real hollywood story
chippendale rescue rangers the show that
defined the generation and turned two
unknown chipmunks into international
superstars
but his success took chippendale to new
heights to many more seasons of the
rescue rangers we were living the dream
dancing the roger rabbit with roger
rabbit
no one ever imagined
it could all come crashing down
torn by vanity you look different hey
it's no secret i had the cgi surgery
done
consumed by temptation my love of cheese
got the best of me i just love it so
much more please
more please
is it possible that two living legends
are destined to reunite
i'm thinking reboot nobody wants a
reboot
it's a rescue ranger you need a disguise
or something grab the first thing you
can
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this place looks weird remember that
animation style where everything looked
real but nothing looked right who are
you
are you talking to us obviously but it
looks like you're talking to that window
it actually looks like i'm looking right
at you okay look at my eyes looking
right at your eyes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
everybody here for the interview
me too
what do you drive
i got the jet bike they're ready to see
you mr crew oh good great
[Music]
here we go
distinguished villains
my name is cru
i feel like i'm talking too loud even
though our proximity doesn't require
this kind of volume
you seriously think a puny little child
can be a villain
yes i am pretty despicable you don't
want to cross me
come back when you've got something evil
to impress me
[Music]
i'll distract them
i'll handle this
this is the biggest day of my life
this kid just stole something from the
world's villains
[Music]
are you pulling on my legs right now
otto where's the stone oh
[Music]
did you just trade my future
for a petra
i didn't mean to scare you now where's
groom
this is the day pass part two embarks on
his journey around the world in 80 days
no less thank you everyone thank you
passport too
my sweet little baby boy going around
the world i don't think so
mom
i need to explore any cars i am tired of
living in the shadow you know what specs
i'm tired of living in a shadow too how
about tomorrow morning i break you out
of this crib and we get on that early
ferry together around the world
[Music]
we're gonna die we're gonna die this is
[Music]
oh great and smoky god of flame and lava
if you want us to sacrifice her send us
a sign
[Applause]
what brings you two into this jungle we
had this idea of beating juan frog de
leon's record by walking how old school
well how would you do it by flying frogs
can't fly frogs who build planes can
on
[Music]
now let's get the ferry there and finish
your trip
wow
[Music]
it's so incredible
[Music]
engine stopped working no need to panic
we're doomed there we go
hmm quicksand how far can your tongue
reach
[Music]
[Music]
how did you get
how have you been
it's a long story
is this the room you grew up in uh it is
but uh my my dorm room is very adult
right no of course
hey are these your drawings what no no
good
i missed you too
okay
so
what are you doing here
i mean i i thought i'd
never see you again
want to get out of here
i'm
grounded
bummer
is spider-man grounded
um
i mean
[Music]
oh
[Music]
a year of work for a four-minute flight
isn't that something we're all ready if
you are sir well let's go find out at
this
thank you
[Music]
buzz lightyear mission log
after a full year of being marooned on
this planet
our first test flight is a go
[Music]
but get everyone home good luck
captaining
roger that
[Applause]
there's
[Music]
just a massive robot
[Music]
that was utterly terrifying and i regret
having joined you
right here
i can provide sleep sounds if you like i
have several options summer night ocean
paradise whale calls no no white noise
is fine very well good night socks good
night buzz
you're invited to a royally loony movie
event
is someone here a long-lost member of
the royal family hey that's me
meet the new royal family king tweety
first of his name
now this is the light
this pillar this bird path this plush
carpet is for me being king is the
greatest
with new royal subjects
i'm used to getting attention but this
is really something else hey dude stop
for a place called the canary island
there sure are a lot of dogs here
that's my brother
and old royal problems
we'll just have to make sure this new
king has an accident as well
i can't let diego in his goons her tweet
he won't survive the day
[Music]
huh
don't miss the all-new king tweety movie
event
[Music]
look for it on digital and dvd
on the outside
the five of you are villains
predators
remorseless sociopaths
oh stop you making me vlogs
we're the bad guys
and this is the crew mr snake serpentine
safe cracking machine imagine houdini
but with no arms jackpot yes
miss tarantula our in-house tech wizard
where'd you learn to do that mostly
youtube mr piranha he's brave crazy
and mr shark master of disguise his
greatest trick stealing the mona lisa
disguised as the mona lisa
and rounding out the crew is me the big
bad wolf we may be bad but we're so good
at it
we're out of here so long suckers
well this just got a little
no
weird
if only we were given a chance to be
anything more than criminals if you want
to stay out of jail you need to go good
what are you doing we're gonna pretend
to go good the bad guys become the good
guys so we can stay in the band guys
it's fantastic wolf you're a genius
welcome to the first day of the rest of
your best life look it's a cat stuck in
a tree what does your heart tell you to
do a good person would
smack it in it stab it saute this is so
obvious i want you to save it
we're more than just scary villains they
love us you're such a good boy
maybe i don't want to be a what a bad
guy no no
no
we'll always be bad guys
let's try something simpler i'm going to
give you a push-pull just for me no to
share this is gonna taste extra squeaky
nope
sucka is it i'll teach you the [ __ ]
totally worth it
this is it abe
moment of truth
remember might be keys to success don't
screw up
come on
i can't watch
but i can't look away
[Applause]
[Music]
when your uncle upon and i went
searching for the hamster of darkness
what the
finding you
was the best thing
that ever happened to
me i can't believe we got to be seen
with that freak chicken here everybody
laughs at me dad would you expect he's
mostly chicken no he's mostly hair check
your hair sounds like they're cheering
for you chicken hair chicken hair
chicken
if i can bring back the hamster of
darkness everyone shall accept me
i'm okay
need a guide i'm meg
follow in my footsteps and you'll be
okay well that's too bad looks like
we'll have to head back
follow me
[Music]
to enter the temple one must pass the
three deadly trials
why can't it ever be two trials
[Music]
i'm going down don't move
all of us are born with things that make
us different
who's ready to ride
[Music]
the only choice we have is recognize
that our differences are what makes us
special
here we go
oh
please you couldn't have brought the
extra large whip could you meg
how many flying hairs have you ever seen
you have wings don't you i can't fly
i can't fly
in a secret place deep inside the forest
the golden egg has chosen i'm a master
rabbit candidate the city rabbit they
make sure every kid gets all of their
easter eggs young rabbits get some
special training if you want to become a
master rabbit you have to take
responsibility you're a rabbit yourself
i know how to get the eggs that's mount
chicken tomorrow we'll steal all the
eggs from up there and on easter sunday
smashed do you trust me with all our
hearts
[Music]
perhaps now a fox will have to join
forces with a rabbit to save easter
[Music]
together
together
oh i want to pack you all over
the giant serpent defeated
the princess was free at last tears
sparkled in her eyes like
the cloak there was no place for a
fragile girl like you sweetie white
right to be continued
[Music]
princess barbara never lived by the
rules
until tradition caught up with her
princess barbara
i'm glad to welcome you all honor of my
daughter barbara's
wedding what
let's walk highness fireball what
fireball it's a pony
that's a pony
darling
i can't marry that horrid man
now she's getting a crash course
on what it's like out in the wild
who are you i swear i didn't touch
anything
you're princess barbara yes today is
your lucky day hoo-man we're going to
sell you back to the palace what to the
palace
a royal kid
not to my dad's palace
she's been kidnapped we have to act fast
here you are runner
whoa
[Music]
forget it she's not your kind
what do you see in her she has no horns
no fur
my heart will reveal you're the kindest
monster in the world all this is mine
life is an adventure
together
featuring the voices of paulie shore
haley duff and john heater i ran away to
the ends of the earth to look for my
prince
did you
i found him
my sweet monster
[Music]
what
[Music]
[Music]
this is a little song full of danger
everywhere but don't you wear it all
done
[Music]
[Music]
bodies they are his painful friends that
will always keep him happy and safe
fearless
[Music]
monsters
i miss summers by the water with mom and
dad i thought maybe you might have left
that book at home this time wouldn't
your parents want you to start making
some stories of your own these are my
stories
yeah
[Music]
way to make an entrance man
it's good to be
[Applause]
to the summer back dance off hit it
funnel
what what's happening
toby is in trouble he used his dark
magic to change guards into mindless
slaves the key to defeating is the great
and powerful storm unicorn we have to
find him i am the great storm unicorn
wait you can talk of course i can speak
dragon
pig
[Music]
there's no way we can do this
we're a team
we stick together come on yeah yes
yes boogie
it's time to taste that thunder
what is going on
it's a long story when every villain in
the dc multiverse unites to form the
legion of dunes
one team of heroes
you guys are in trouble now is not going
to be enough for one movie you know you
might want to bring the big guns with
you on this mission
what if i told you i hold the power to
get rid of every superhero
they'll need all the help they can get
i sure do things
differently here the entire multiverse
is at stake but if i lose control what
if i hurt someone you might be surprised
what darkness can do if you give it a
chance
i know harleen diana she's not evil but
once this girl's not with anybody
it's gonna be mayhem great scott what is
this we eat crises have catastrophic
proportions for breakfast that's what
happens to any superhero dumb enough to
face the legion of doom
time to kick some legion butt
teen titans go and dc superhero girls
mayhem in the multiverse look for it on
digital blu-ray and dvd
[Music]
bye